apologies everyone we were due to start
now but we're just gonna just got a
couple of things you need to check
before we do we'll try to be quick
right good evening everybody apologies
for the delay to start we had to go over
a few pieces of documentation make sure
everything was all straight I introduced
myself my name is Danny Kendal I'm
chairman of this committee and I'll be
chairing her tonight's planning
committee in accordance to the rules and
procedures set out in the inside cover
of your agenda here tonight a few bits
of housekeeping before we get started if
I could remind everyone members and
members of the public please to make
sure their mobile phones turned off or
at least silent to avoid any
embarrassing interruptions and also to
make members of the public aware of the
fact that the meeting is being recorded
tonight videoed so should you wish the
next day or two you'll be able to review
tonight's proceedings at home in your
own time should you really want to watch
it all over again that being said let's
go to item 1 electroclash you can
actually ask people to introduce
themselves on top here please thank you
Thank You Jeremy list you've Oscar
committee services nation s legal
services my name is Richard Gardner
I'm the Planning Manager for tonight's
meeting my role is to provide impartial
advice to clarify any planning issues
that arise and to assist members
decision taking I'm bound by the Royal
Town Planning Institute code of
Professional Conduct and planning
committee members aren't bound by advice
from officers or by their
recommendations
Thompson planner
Joubert planner Victoria Chataway Senior
Planner wonderful thank you so moved to
item 1 apologies for absence this item
to disclose interests capsule Rock I
have an interest in 1803 4 to 5 in that
I'm the ward member I proposed to speak
on that item are we will be withdrawing
from the committee for the consideration
of that item therefore I will not be
voting upon it yeah any further
yes council Dixon fantastic thank you
any further disclosures have interest no
brilliant item 3 to confirm assignments
of the meeting held on the 10th of July
you all content by sign those
thank you I'll do that at the end right
we can move to our first application
then tonight which is item 4 found on
page seven of your agendas this
application reference 18 / 0 3 4 2 5 /
ful and this for the woods Vicarage Road
Knapton Vicarage Road sorry naps on the
hill for the erection of two-story 3 bed
2 touched house presenting officer Paul
Thompson over to you Thank You counselor
the site is within the built a barrier
boundary draft build a very boundary of
Knapton on the hill it's on a hill
overlooking the valley below it's
roughly where the black spot is on the
map residential development is
acceptable in principle on this site
this is a site plan closer in the
application site is outlined in red with
the visibility's place to left in right
the red buildings here are listed and
green circle represents a tree
preservation order which isn't affected
by this develop
the land is currently in use as sort of
overgrown garden - this property here
which is the woods the woods is in the
same ownership as the application site
this is a proposed layout two parking
spaces to the front and one parking
space for the woods here which is just
outside the application site there's
large sycamore tree at the top left
which isn't protected in any particular
respect but we have proposed conditions
to protect it the building proposed is
roughly in line with the neighboring
properties and will maintain the
building line these are the elevations
during the course of the application we
the applicant has amended the proposal
to remove a balcony at the front and to
have flats eaves and to reduce the width
to make room for the parking and to
reduce the proportions of the windows in
relation to the gable end this is in
plan form and it's inverted from the
normal arrangement so you have living
accommodation on the first floor and
bedrooms on the ground-floor suggested
topography of the site which here is
sloped up from the road to the to the
back of the site this is taken from the
existing parking space for the woods as
a single parking space sort of cut into
the slope looking up towards the window
to living accommodation on the side
elevation
this is shows the adjoining buildings is
a garage too high over cottage on the
left of the picture and the woods itself
is on the right is showing a fairly
disparate facing materials the boundary
wall across the front of the site will
be removed as part of this application
here are some other views along by the
application site again you can see a
variety of facing materials and
architectural styles this is opposite
the application site looking down over
the new housing estate towards the
valley shows the the topography of the
surrounding landscape and also the
potential for views of the site from
over long distances so as we see the key
issues here that have been during the
process of being the design and the
parking arrangements
these have been resolved during the
process by amendments and to our
satisfaction as planners the parking on
site parking complies with our standards
in the development requirements
supplementary planning document there's
no highways objection thank you Paul
Wright we move to our first speaker on
this councillor Rach
for welcome Council Rock Thank You mr.
chairman but sir you have five minutes I
think I've got three slides if they
could be found
shall I pause - yeah just give us a
second fighters okay street scene Bob
first please before that that's it you
have five minutes if you remain seated
for any questions at the end over to you
if you let me know at four and a half
minutes oh I should have finished Bob
yes I will I think the words finely
balanced to crop up several times in
considering this application I think
you'll find them in the report firstly
we'll have found out the parish council
withdrew their objection two days ago
when they were told about a number of
details by the applicant and these were
about modifications to the design that
would have improved the in Congress
appearance in the street scene this
seemed to have tipped the balance into
removing their objection so I'd like to
talk about design first and parking in a
minute personally I like contemporary
design and I do think that the new and
the old can be made to blend in
sometimes however in this case it is all
about context and setting and this is
about the most prominent position in
Knapton I don't think the drawings give
a clear enough impression of this so
I've taken a few pictures to show the
committee the run of dwellings on the
same side of the road and also opposite
and here I'd like to refer you to policy
cs9 section b to the society surrounded
by heritage buildings including the
granary opposite which is bottom left in
this slide incidentally only last month
the plumbing inspector dismissed an
appeal on the meadow opposite adjacent
to the granary on the basis of the
importance of the landscape here the
other hand is the other three or three
pictures or on a run on the same side
rode over about 70 meters to the
northeast and as was said two of these
are listed could have the next slide
please number two it is true there is a
Victorian semi and one seventies house
in this room
however the Heritage theme continues
about 60 meters to the southeast within
the adjacent high of a house and beyond
that a row of cottage set back over hack
World Bank which you can see where that
road comes in it's for members to judge
how in Congress this proposed dwelling
will be in this setting in the prominent
part of the village
however its parking could have the next
slide please and from last one
however it's parking and safety that
concerns me most notwithstanding the
reported highways comments I've spoken
to the highways officer at some length
he conceded he had not visited the site
to look at it since the parking had been
being arranged quite significantly and
therefore not considered on such a visit
the points I'm about to make firstly I
draw your attention to the picture top
left traffic enters at an acute I'm
going to Vicarage Road where drivers are
forced to look over their shoulder
before immediately passing this science
secondly the three spaces represent
parking between walls cars will have to
come out quite straight without the
opportunity to be swung or angled within
the site or over a foot wide which
drivers would otherwise normally and
naturally do there is no foot weight
and/or any significant verge here
furthermore coming out from close behind
the walls of the proposed house and the
Victorian semi and views then being
obstructed by hedges and walls not in
the control of the occupant and a curve
in the road means that visions plays are
compromised if there was to be a traffic
conflict which I think is likely there
is limited scope for traffic avoidance
because there are no foot ways and the
area opposite has cars parked there
virtually all the time this is the
primary route through the village these
photographs were taken in the middle of
the day but it's school time this road
can be quite busy now just a word on
parking numbers the new proposed
dwelling is at the side guard with the
original wood swimming I can't help
looking at the scheme as a whole and
noting where the boundary line is set
has a bearing on parking as has been
pointed out both properties are in the
control of the applicant the semi is
currently being extended parking has
been a particular problem this spot it's
in living memory the wood semi has not
had an occupant with a car
I can tell you it practically will have
to accommodate an extra four vehicles
from this scheme as a whole maybe I'm
not an expert on the current and
emerging car parking standards but
having looked at the SPD it seems to me
requires four spaces 30 seconds it seems
to me the standards are not fully met I
think that should be fully met that's
the matter is critical I'm always
reluctant to recommend a site visit but
this might be a case with one run over
by five seconds did not know it's okay
you still have 50 eventually right do
you have any questions yes cats Lipari
Thank You chair good evening Council
Rock just wondered whether you could
just divine you're planning reasons for
objecting to this application I'm sorry
I perhaps have haven't really picked up
the your key planning reasons for
objection muted objection about the
design because I recognize that is a
matter of a degree of opinion and taste
and so forth however if you look at the
elevations when we have a chance you'll
find it's quite a modern contemporary
design with fully glazed gable ends now
I had the opportunity at the parish
council meeting where the Parish Council
determined to withdraw their objection
which on that basis and I'm trying to
represent the views of others day quite
fairly but I gather and I'm sure the
officer could explain this further that
the reach higher and there's more
glazing and there were different
materials so the Parish Council felt
that the incongruity of the design was
not as strong as if it was but there is
a question whether it fits into the
street scene I have that reservation as
well but I could accept that it perhaps
could be a HUD so is it just the because
of
but the second point which are as I said
in my comments what really concerns me
is the issue of highway safety and
parking because that has been a
particular problem that sight and
speaking to the the people that live
nearby there have been difficulties
there before when there were less cars
around its parking the highways on
concern that's how did you want to come
back I just ripped now I just wanted
clarity so obviously highways have no
who are the experts have no objection
but you you still feel that the highways
are incorrect in their assumption of
this application that's why I went to
the trouble of tracking down the
highways officer on the first person I
asked him is have you looked at this
site and his answer was yes but not
since the site has been amended perhaps
come back to it in points of
clarification if that's okay later on
any other questions that case Council
Rock thank you very much do you have any
points of clarification councillor
Richards then against the parent so
first of all could you please show me on
screen should make you very clear
exactly what is being proposed for
parking I can see two cars on the
left-hand side and one on the right it
is it as simple as that just to that
form right and in your so annual report
you've said normally you'll expect two
spaces for dwelling other size however
in this instance you're happy with one I
don't understand
and I'd understand what Grampian
conditioners could you explain to me the
thinking be honest okay okay so the new
dwelling which is the one inside the
redline boundary there with the two
spaces attached to it that needs her
standard starts that's what we expect
for a three bed house that's what the
SPD says the woods has one space at the
moment which we saw in one of the photos
certainly when I visited the site it
wasn't really in a usable condition as
councillor akka said it hasn't been used
for many years it was overgrown so this
one space moving to its new location
immediately adjoining the woods as
opposed to being the opposite of the
garden essentially replicates the
existing arrangement we can't really
force them to provide more parking for
the existing dwelling because this
development isn't causing that problem
it's that problem already exists so in
short the new site does comply with our
SPD which is fine and by virtue of the
fact there is only one already on the
existing woods and it happens to be
being made better you're satisfied the
dimensions of the replacement space are
better than the existing Thank You
councillor Perry
it's just confirmation that highways
maintain no objection for this
application yes a correspondence from
Dave Pilcher County highways yesterday -
the - not basically there's no
additional comments after there very
quickly the count the highways
department did visit the site today in
the process obviously the proposal has
been amended since then but they have
visited the site in person and they have
had they each set of amendments so they
are aware of the situation on the ground
yes right okay council bonds
we got a street scene picture wise the
ward member was concerned about in there
yeah that's okay councillor Dixon Thank
You chairman looking at the position for
those parking spaces would be right in
thinking that car parking on the woods
at the present time you can't
necessarily leave the site always in
forward gear
and therefore is there any change in
that because certainly looking at those
drawings of either you go in you either
reverse on to the site or you reverse
out of the site that doesn't seem to
maintaining space is that correct
correct yes right should we go to the
debate I want to start councillor
Richardson Council Perry thank you
so taking a consideration the
representation I made by cancer off in
the discussion we just had I'm entirely
comfortable with what's been proposed
here so I will propose that we grant in
line with his office's recommendation
councillor Perry Thank You chair happy
to second the proposal on the basis that
we have no no planning reasons that
reflect substantial harm and if if we
were to go down the route of a refusal
this would easily be turned over at
appeal with cost to the council there's
nothing in front of me that reflects
that it is out of policy so I'm very
happy to second proposal thank you I do
agree actually with what's been said so
far
anybody else want to speak in the debate
should we go to the vote it's been
proposed that we grant the application
all those in favor please show the
committee results to grant application
reference 18 / 0 3 4 2 5 / ful we move
to our second item is item 5 and found
on page 19 if your agenda tonight this
is application reference 19 / 0 1 2 7 6
/ very and it's for the land on the
north side of plot 2 Green Lane ox Hill
essentially well a number of different
changes being made there that proved
with room sizes circulation to make new
dwelling more and keeping with new
neighboring properties and to approve
attached and hindered drawings
presenting officer his Joseph Brooke
sure over to you thank you the site is
located on the edge of Fox Hill and his
president the open land
this is indicated by the black belt
before you assault is between friend
railings arisen approved for the plots
under 14 star zero two two four four
such a beauty as indicated in the
officers report the four bedroom running
to the west of the principal elevation
which has been completed folks view and
there's two dwellings to the east
surface and knees to toe and it's just
that side is located exactly in between
this application specifically seeking
design and layout alterations of the two
drivers approved in 2018 eighteen star
zero one three five seven full okay due
to the complex history of the site and
to establish the contacts this
application the plan before you is the
approved site plan for application
eighteen size 135 seven foot which is
what the applicant is seeking to vary as
part of this application if you please
know the front elevation building line
and infill plot there so this is the
floor that was a prudent 2019 secondly
the application before you now he's 18 /
zero to nine one five very you'll see it
on the update sheet in particular and
this was a period on the 27th of
November 2018
this is expand permission and is
considered to be a realistic fullback
position for the applicant please note
on this application the additional floor
space attitude one is the principal
elevation so this has been approved in
2018 that's the fundamental change as
you can see now the plan before you is
what the applicant is seeking to vary as
part of this application as you can see
the principal elevation from the full
will be extended but this does already
have it's done permission from the
previous very large main difference is
the infill to rear at the back of the
plot
this is the floorplans indicate in the
proposed additions especially to the
rear of the plots so you see is the
additional floor space there and fit in
the gap and you'll see better on the
elevation lines but there is a small
adjustment
Ruffo doesn't affect the ridge so this
is the adjustment so refi pitching down
to create the additional space and this
is the rear elevations and the in for
the plops that's how you the applicant
is proposing to vary and then fill and
then align the rear built in line this
is a site as it currently stands so
you've got the two drawings approved so
right which are basically completed
after the site visit yesterday and they
were indwelling over you this is oaks
view and that's the final application as
you can see for you there also
recommendations for approval because
it's considered that the visual impact
the proposal is minimal especially with
due regard to what has already been
previously approved as mentioned within
this presentation if you please note as
I've already stated on the update see
additional planning history has been
amended or which is contained in the
rather than planning history thank you
Thank You Jay alright good our first
speaker
mr. Ian ray please agent
welcome mr. ray so you have three
minutes
if you remain seated at the end for any
questions if I give you a warning at the
last 30 seconds okay that gets over to
you thank you the variation plan
application that is before you is for
the infilling the rear left hand corner
of the approved footprint and move in
the first floor war outwards detailed
planning permission already exist for
these houses this is merely an
application to slightly amend the
approved plans the overall design of
these houses has not changed there are
similar desire to the joining houses
that have recently been constructed the
ground floor in film it is very small
three point four six meters are three
point seven meters and serves only to
square off the footprint the third floor
wall moves there by mere 760 millimeters
this were not the impact on any
neighboring properties they do not
extend any further to the rear past
existing properties than what has
already been approved refer that members
of the public parish council may have
misunderstood or misread the description
the development or drawings as
references me mater over development and
being out of keeping with neighboring
properties we cannot see how the small
rear infill and the minor increase in
the first floor and yet the master of
development nor that they are active
keeping when they match almost the two
properties to the right deprecation is
the for support to the planning
department and board member and there's
a very minor variation I'm surprised
it's here before this committee we
assume you know they're exporting your
planning department in following their
recommendation and approve this
application thank you thank you very
much mr. a any questions for the
applicants agent
that case mr. right thank you very much
for coming thank you right we go to our
next speaker councillor fielding the
ward member it be possible for Liz
Stuart who is the next door neighbor who
is also on the parish council to come up
with many cases to speak so we don't
have to ask questions I'm sorry fair
enough we have to have prior warning of
it apologies right counselor Fielding's
so you have five minutes over to you
fellow councillors this is very much in
line with my objections on previous
developments where you're putting
squeezing in houses and reducing the
Society of distances between them they
also the Ox Hill parish plan which seems
to be ignored
yet again has referred to two to three
bedroom houses that the parish want this
one is forgot what I would class as a
creep in three stages from a hundred and
fifty-one square meters in may 18 to 171
square meters in October 18 and now to
292 200 square meters in May 1940 the
proposed increase in size that these
properties would potentially extend past
the rear of the properties on either
side thereby reducing privacy for the
properties the basically this creep is
part and parcel with making it into four
bedrooms which the village itself
doesn't need it's more in keeping
three to four bedrooms the proposal is
for two houses similar to the previous
ones so that we have four similar houses
on the road with very individual with
sorry with diverse individual houses now
assist in keeping with a local
environment and if you actually look at
Green Lane you will see all sorts of
development and very few large building
I don't know whether you've got any
visual scenes you can show which is
referred to by the village as the shard
it is a very tall out of character of
building if you go back to the stairs
pictures that one but that one there is
the one that has been designed and built
for this Stuart and it's a character
building you look at the other way can
clear the other way and you see those
two rather grey buildings which are
going to be these two new ones are going
to be very similar to it really is
causing a lot of consternation in the
village and basically I think that they
need to be kept to the size that they
originally agreed and not have this ink
continually increase inside because
probably next time there one another
and square another 10 square feet to add
to it and slowly it will get larger and
larger so thank you can't feel any
questions for a ward member as I
understand it counts the field and your
principal objection is that these
incremental size increases of these
properties conflict with the parish plan
is that correct
a further questions that case counsel
counsel fielding thank you very much for
your time points of clarification
Chancellor Perry the councillor Richards
thank you I just wonder whether the
officers confirm that in line with the
new permitted development rights that
came into force at the end of May this
year the six rear extensions can extend
on a detached property up to six metres
past the original house so if if for
example we reminded to refuse this
application in fact the the the
applicant could actually increase the
rear of the property beyond what is
actually presented in front of us um
there is no permit developments have
extended but there's more regulations
and just the standards and six meters it
also depends on overlooking issues and
the heights of the building 50% and so
forth the problem being with this
application it's nothing's built so it's
a variation application so you can only
consider what's before you in the
variations amended on this application
and I think probably the best way of
showing that is that is the rear of
building alone in torts already been
approved their previous applications
it was just clarification on the
principle that if this was a built
building the applicant more than like
could extend beyond than what is
currently in front of us
you've made your point that counts very
cancer riches thanks Jack could you just
clarify that is still three bedrooms
that we're looking at not four and also
could you show me again your the images
show that the change in size of the at
the actual outer shell of the property
please
sorry guys do you mean this if you could
demonstrate so what what was originally
what has been approved and the how much
doesn't have to be otherwise it'd be
really like that just is showing the
additional floor space I think that
pretty much does it isn't it so it's
those green hatched areas correct the
young thing I would say is the the front
I'm trying to do it most the front
elevation this is where the complexities
come in they're very in the full so the
front elevation has expand permission so
they can fall back to this area so there
it's that they're seeking to extend it
and technically with the full it would
be extending here but they already have
extract permission for not from the very
okay that's fine perfect is four
bedrooms not three cats Arak there's a
similar sort of question to cancel
enriches question could you show us the
elevation that's the view I wanted and
I'm interesting that relationship to the
house and a question of overshadowing
which has been brought up would it be
that elevation that would overshadow the
house to the left understood that
correctly if we judged it to be able to
shuddering it
that's the elevation that is fun it
would be side onto Oak View so sorry
I'll just come off that quickly so that
elevation there lassie in full plot so
it would be on to the side direction of
Oaks you the name of property and in
that plan view the sort of block on the
right-hand side of the outline to the
left it was a sort of open construction
I don't know what you call that I have
potentially such like a carport but -
that's unkind but did you know - meaning
sir
it's not over shouting part of the house
that is a sort of amenity area the
scheme as its proposed meets all the
tests that we would apply so it meets
the 45-degree test for daylight when
applied from the rear windows of the
neighborhood property to that if you
look right here so you can see the
extensions that protrude Knight sides
the side of the house so no more points
of clarification the debate Council
Perry Thank You chair basically on the
basis of what the application we have
before us I can't see any material
planning reason to refuse this therefore
I go straight forward to a proposal to
grant you that counts Richard I'm
entirely happy to second that that I
think the report is know very well
reasoned and I see no reason why we
could reviews thank you anybody else
want to speak in the debate on this okay
let's go to the vote it's been proposed
that we grant all those in favor please
show thank you the committee report
resolves to grant application reference
19 / 0 1 2 76 / very move to item 6
on our agenda which is held on page 29
this is application reference 1900 475
slash ful and it's for haystacks Penn
Lane turn within this is for the
demolition of existing garage and
conservatory in the erection of new
single-story rear extension two-story
side extension first floor rear
extension Newports porch fenestration
alterations and partial render right
presently officers Victoria territory
Thank You chair and thank you for the
description sorry what member you're not
allowed to stay at the table you need to
be on the need to be no no no if you
intend to speak on the application you
need to be with the members of the
public apologies don't worry nice music
thank you thank you chair the site is
indicated by the black dot the this is
the the red line around you for the site
as you can see within the context the
site comprises of a large residential
plot with a large property within it
which is characteristic of the area
those properties are set well back from
the road this is a google image of the
site with the site indicated in with the
blue square above it
the site significantly falls within a
designated Greenbelt and that is a
significant material consideration in
the assessment of this application the
property has previously been extended
before plant planning permission was
granted for a single-story rear
extension in 1979 which is roughly
indicated by the orange oval and then
further consent was granted in 2001 for
a first floor rear extension and a
conservatory those extensions
cumulatively
added up to approximately a fifty nine
percent increase in volume to the
original dwelling so for context and
looking at the proposed scheme we have
existing on the left and
posed on the right the proposal includes
the demolition of the existing garage
and the erection of a two-story side
extension in its place linking to the
existing dwelling house a porch to the
front and to the rear we have a further
first floor rear extension in addition
to those already proposed as well as the
replacement of the conservatory with a
garden room this slide shows that the
floor plans again just for contact
showing that the proposed additions
overall the combination of the existing
extensions and taken into account the
demolition of the conservatory in the
garage and then the proposed development
under this application the cumulative
increase to the original dwelling would
be 82% further context these are the
site side elevations bottom right-hand
side is probably the most changed side
where the two-story extension is
proposed instead of the where the garage
is proposed to be demolished and finally
just for information this is a roof plan
quite clearly showing where the proposed
additions are they are indicated in
yellow in summary I would just say that
the dwelling does fall within the
Greenbelt which is a significant
material consideration in the assessment
of this application your adopted policy
allows for small scale additions to the
original dwelling when it's in the green
belt in order for that not to be
considered to be inappropriate
development in the green belt this
proposal would result in the original
dwelling having been extended by 82% its
officers professional judgment that an
82% volume increase could not be
considered a small scale extension and
as such would be considered
inappropriate development in the green
belt there are no special circumstances
that have been identified that would
overcome this view the recommendation is
to refuse thank you Joe thank you
Victoria right so here our first speaker
Robert McMahon pleased the applicant
[Applause]
welcome so the one right in the middle
there that's it there's no need to sit
too close to the mic it'll pick you up
see you can be relaxed you have three
minutes if you'd remain seated for any
questions at the end and I'll give you a
30-second warning towards the end of
your time okay thank you over to you
good evening chair and members of the
planning committee my wife and I have
lived at haystacks for over six years
the house has been a work in progress
and we now want to improve its
appearance
reorganize the accommodation internally
through the addition of a fourth bedroom
over the garage and also make the
prophecy more secure with driveway gates
haystacks it's in an acre plot is set
back 35 metres from Penn Lane and is
well screened in respective hedges and
mature trees we consider that the
proposals both respect and contribute
the character of Penn Lane in terms of
scale and mass which once extended will
still be considerably smaller than the
neighboring properties the increasing
volume to the original House is actually
79% not the 82 percent as identified
within the committee reports and this
was confirmed by our architects of the
planning officer in question after it
was recalculated there are no objections
to the application and it and it's
supported or was supported by councillor
Atkinson prior to his retirement and
also by councillor Dixon now all parties
consulted have an affinity with the area
the planning officer has stated within
her report that the changes to the
dwelling who would not create any visual
harmful impact to the character in the
street scene the proposals would not
create any overlooking overshadowing or
have an over bed
impact and also the proposed scheme
doesn't have a detrimental impact upon
the wider Arden special landscape home
the planning officer refuses with
proposes to refuse the application
because the garage and accommodation
above it in respect to scale and mass
are inappropriate and will have a
detrimental impact upon the openness and
visual amenity of the green belts and
also the increase in volume of the
property great harm and it is not small
in scale to use this approach seems very
unfair to us as there have been numerous
examples locally where the same policy
issues have arisen which have either
been approved at committee or at appeal
a good example is mill cottage on Penn
Lane where the same planning officer in
2013 recommended approval for an
extension aware the increase in volume
was 80 percent I think it's also
relevant to point out to apply a volume
increase restriction all depends upon
the starting point of the original
housing respective size pace tax was a
small 3-bedroom house and surely the
application of planning policy is all
about context in determining the
application we would welcome a pragmatic
of 36 where it is considered on its own
merits we don't believe that the impact
is we don't believe that it impacts
detrimental e on the openness and a
visual amenity of the green belt and we
believe that the changes proposed our
proportions thank you for your time
in considering in our application thank
you very much
questions councillor bonds the first
picture we saw looked to me as though it
was an extension at the back of the last
picture we saw seem to burn laden in the
roof
yes well any of you all started trying
to get the to to jail yes the the
obviously in terms of the original
property you can see that we are
intending to
place the conservatory with that with a
garden room which we can use all the
time this particular shot here is
misleading in so far as the the two
towards the rear of the garage which is
to the left hand side of the picture
that was part and parcel of the original
dwelling when it was built
insofar as there was a small storeroom
to the rear of the garage
that was originally converted into a
utility so the the piece or the the
building structure to the left-hand side
of that picture is is original the other
bits that you can see are infill and
what we're intending to do is not
demolish the garage in total but extend
it and then build above it so that we
can create the fourth bedroom that we
will need to future-proof our house in
terms of our future needs thank you
thank you thank you for your
presentation so um but I don't know if
you know that I'm gonna ask the office
of the same question do you know roughly
what the percentage increase is of the
property from how it is today to what
you're proposing you don't know that's
fine I don't know the answer to that
question I haven't got those
calculations with me but I can tell you
that the the property from it was first
built to how we are how we're presenting
the property today in terms of the
extensions it's a 79 percent thank you
Kenta Perry thank you good evening there
wasn't no special circumstances
particularly highlighted in the pool I
just wondered whether there was anything
that you wanted to highlight two men so
committed save me know that there are no
special circumstances I mean my wife and
I are wanting to extend the house to
future-proof it to meet our changing
needs particularly in terms of the care
of
elderly family members at the Laura I
can't stop you say there are no special
conservatives and it's just
future-proofing that's a cow I'll leave
it alone oh that's okay
any further questions that's fantastic
that get mister moment thank you very
much of your time tonight
we go to our ward member the next
speaker
right welcome counselor Dixon so you
have five minutes
feel really main seat of any questions
at the end and I'll give you a warning
at 30 seconds over to you members if I
go back to our training in May I recall
much emphasis on balancing the various
aspects and giving our own assessment as
to how much weight we Accord to each
element of applications our role is to
assess each case on its merits and
determine whether or not we agree with
the balance made by the planning officer
this application is recommended for
refusal on only one ground that the
proposed additions to the property will
have a detrimental impact and harmony
openness of the Greenbelt I will keep my
comments to this one aspect let me show
you the photographs of this area
Victoria those aren't mine that's that's
the first one that's number one pen
laying the location haystacks broad Lane
is the next picture very indicative of
the open nature of the streets in the
views towards the village of Tanith and
finally pull head lane these lanes
formed three of the four sites of the
light Brook Park Golf Course right this
next photograph taken from a public
footpath across opened countryside next
please
next that's the one shows two properties
a bungalow on the left and behind the
spike screen of trees on the right a
two-story large house built 20 years ago
to replace a bungalow with a low pitch
roof that house does impact upon the
openness and the Greenbelt but whilst
Greenbelt legislation has not changed
the aim being to prevent urban sprawl by
keeping land permanently open the
implementation of that legislation has
changed in the 1990s SDC policy enabled
properties to be replaced provided the
footprint did not increase by more than
30%
thus a two-story mansion replaced a
low-rise bungalow in another instance a
small wooden prefab with
with the five or six bedroom house the
implementation of Greenbelt legislation
changed the FTC policy began to use a
guideline of 30 percent by volume
instead of footprint but this too had to
change when permitted development rights
enabled extensions beyond this nominal
guidelines if this hip roof bungalow had
an 8 meter rear extension it would be a
45 degree increase and if the attached
garage had been within the form of the
bungalow and not a forward projection
such an 8 meter extension would be about
the 58% and it would be easy to imagine
a similar bungalow with a lower pitched
roof in such an instance an extension
may perhaps be 65% numbers therefore are
not the means whereby to assess the
impact on the openness of the Greenbelt
think what an and trace of 30% would be
to these three homes recently
constructed on garden land
let me now look to a decision made by
SDC last summer brought an application
also backing onto the golf course I
quote from the officer's report the new
dwellings would not be seen as an
encroachment into the open countryside
and further whilst the built form within
the site would be increased I am
satisfied that this would appear as
limited in Felton and it is most
important would preserve the openness of
the site within the wider street scene
and landscape views that site is still
being developed in these pictures show
what has become of the garden land
personally I think this has had a
detrimental impact upon the openness of
the site within the wider street scene
as does everyone who speaks to me about
this development
turning now to haystacks with the
addition of the proposed extensions have
a detrimental impact upon the street
scene and landscape views is there any
encroachment into open countryside my
asset to both of these questions is
there is no impact upon the street scene
and no encroachment into open
countryside the officers suggests that
very special circumstances are required
to permit this applique
I maintain that only applies if members
consider that there is harm to the
openness of the Greenbelt as a result of
these proposed extensions members will
appreciate that how we live today has
changed since the days when his property
was built conservatives ensuite
bathrooms utility rooms we're never
mentioned when I grew up in the 50s we
now see homes with all these aspects as
normal as well as home offices and
studies we are all hopeful of living
longer
we need homes capable of accommodating
three generations after a recent council
meeting we accepted and aimed to reduce
carbon impacts to zero by 2030 seconds
this requires that we reuse and adapt
rather than replace our assets we should
therefore be very wary of encouraging
the demolition of homes and instead
permit them to be adapted for modern
living to permit a three-bedroom house
to be transformed into a modern
four-bedroom home capable of
accommodating three generations where
there is no impact upon the openness of
the Greenbelt should be the decision we
make this evening thank you any
questions that is absolutely spot-on
five minutes absolutely perfect thank
you right any questions for the ward
member please you've given us there is a
reference to policies on new builds and
on replacement dwellings rather than
just on an extension is it and in the
report the officers laid out the
considerations that we need to give when
we're looking at extensions clearly she
you in that report has determined that
the scale and massing of what's been
proposed breaches those if we're to
overturn that as a committee we have to
have very strong and solid planning
reasons I'm I was struggling to cuz
you're seeking resort of information now
I'm trying to find out exactly what they
are from you could you be concise and
clear on those please I think the
planning reasons I think the officers
report con details the planning reasons
for permitting if you like or not
permitting it is a matter of judgment
between the balance we actually
in other words their recommendation is
to refuse because of the impact upon the
openness of the Greenbelt if and they
basically say that impact is because
it's an 82% or a 79% extension on an
original house a three-bedroom house
built in the 1950s
now essentially my view is that
essentially if there is no impact upon
the street scene and no impact upon the
open countryside as I mentioned to that
previous officer's report which I had on
a different application admittedly that
site there was a demolition of a house
and it was replaced and the officer's
report said that that will not be an
impact upon the openness of the College
Council it so I I don't need to Britt
and reread what you've already told me I
asked you to be concise and and if you
could I think what you're saying is you
just disagree I do disagree with the
balance that has been made by the
Planning Officers capsule and the street
scene which is CS now I know whatever
so all the houses are big asses
he said yes this is a three-bedroom
detached house in pen Lane most of its
neighbors and most of the properties in
there are five and six bedroom houses I
have to say the plan with parish council
often have a an attitude towards
objecting etc they saw no issue with
this one and in fact I understand I
wasn't there but I understand the
comment was made by the parish council
this can I ask you to come back the
question would you say Council Dixon
would you say this is reflective of the
street scene as it is I think that was
why your questions go now okay so you
saying the other houses a large wrong
they're all larger than that even this
one after a night engine will still be
the smallest in the okay then think
counselor barns are services as good as
you're gonna get for a street scene
photos thank you it gives you an idea of
the size in the setting right other
questions for the ward member okay
councillor Dixon thank you very much
thank you if you could just take half
the night for me as well thank you right
points of clarification I asked the the
applicant this question and if I may
which I'd like to watch the same one do
you know what the rough percentage
increase would be from what is there now
currently on site so what has been
proposed so we've just done that
calculations because you have to look at
the incremental change each time it's
it's not that straightforward but the
answer we got two is sixteen point five
percent from the previous extensions
okay and so that's brilliant thank you
um so just so I'm clear you're saying we
obviously what you're saying is we have
to consider what has been there before
obviously your list within the report
says cumulative effect proposed scheme
together with previous development a
site that's part of the explanation
notes of policy
our core strategy isn't it so yeah so
our explanation of notes talked about
the original dwelling and that's part of
the assessment and that comes also from
the MPP F which talks about percentage
in Tikrit not percentage increase but
disproportionate to the original
dwelling so it's not just our our
policies which are quite clear but it is
national policy as well we have to look
at the overall accumulative effect from
from first built yes thank you thank you
chairman the applicant alluded to other
properties and on an appeal in the same
Road where there were other 80 percent
increases that had been granted which
seems to be different tortoises in the
in your report is it can you comment
upon that doesn't allude to are we aware
of any other applicants that might be
precedent to say you're able to breach
the gardens by that degree yeah well the
recommendation is based on an objection
in principle there will be other
buildings in the area that will have
different sized trees and I've had
different reasons they may have been
granted because that were very special
circumstances but what we don't do is a
trawl of all the other permissions in
the area to check that as we've heard
already to each case on its own merits
and the merits of this one are affected
by the fact that it's within the green
belt and current policy therefore has to
apply CATSA Perry yes it's just sort of
some clarification if the committee were
minded to grant what reasons in terms of
impact on the openness and impact on the
street area be sufficient in terms of
material planning reasons
do you mean absence of impact so in
terms of the design bit minimal a lack
of the impact on the openness or the
streets a limited impact limited limited
him because obviously any any form of
planning application will have an impact
I'd just like to have clarification and
whether they would be valid reasons that
we would have to give as material
planning reasons if we went if we
reminded yes you've just got to bear in
mind that some of the things you say
would have said there would would be
expected of any application so for
example if you decide the designs
acceptable that's neutral that doesn't
weigh in favor of overriding Greenbelt
policy because all applications would
have to do that but what you might do is
look at the policy which obviously talks
about it needing to be small-scale and
conclude that this is small-scale points
should we go to the debate so I think
we've said the 16 and a half percent
increase from current to proposed is not
it could be deemed to be small-scale and
if we were just looking at that as it
was then I don't think we'd be having
this debate equally I wonder whether if
it was an entire replacement dwelling
well whether we would still be having
the same debate but the reality is we do
have them this is national policy and
our own core strategy policy that we do
have to consider the original building
size and whether it's 79 percent or 82%
is an increase that that is material
that is an enormous increase in the
original one we're talking Castle Rock
about other permissions and setting
precedents as we've heard it's the every
caters on its own merits and there will
be special circumstances that may
permitted a particular development it
might have been at those rather than
extensions were replacements I don't
think we can draw conclusions from
something else that has been granted
when this is what we're looking at
the evidence that has been presented to
us and thinking to some of the questions
that counts the power but just now I
think my issue one was searching for
reasons in the absence of any very clear
reasons to grant something tells me
there's something wrong and whilst I
would love to see the this gentleman and
his family extend their home national
policy and our local policy clearly show
that we shouldn't be permitting it and
unfortunately on that basis I'm gonna
have to propose that we go with officers
recommendation and refuse planning
permission Thank You councillor Barnes
you indicated next I don't agree with
the last speaker in the respective the
impact on the special landscape area no
it's also in my eyes in policy cs9 it
fixes free scene and to me that's too
important practice
I appreciate it's the green belt and we
want the save the green belt but we had
one some months ago where we lost on
appeal for the simple reason this is
design looked okay I suppose if you like
we we didn't like that is arm but the
inspector did so I'm concerned it's very
similar to the other house in the road
which and it's isn't it just support
it's down here the landscape area I
don't think it will look at a place and
I feel I could pervert it with the
appropriate conditions in the respective
two years nine council Rock
I think mr. chairman well captain Dixon
made a very powerful argument for
granting this application from afraid I
wasn't persuade to be my question about
other appeal decisions was to see if we
could learn anything from those and in
fact I agree with everything that
council writ had said
if if the numbers we were looking at
rather than 30 percent 38 or 40 - what
one could have been looking at what it
says in our policy about interpretation
of it one could imagine but anybody be
78 or 82 percent this is a huge
difference between that and we've heard
it's not only our policy it's national
policy so I'm afraid if I believe cancer
which had made a proposal to go along
with the officers recommendation refuse
it and I would second that
thank you Perry Thank You Jay I have
every I do sympathise with the
applicants on this particular submission
and you might have gathered by the line
of my questioning I was trying to see if
there was a fairly substantial planning
reason to to go against the officers
recommendation I'm a great believer in
that we have to we have our call
strategy policy but more importantly
than that is the NDP F guidelines which
are spell it out particularly on
disproportionate size of extensions and
therefore it is with regret that I will
be going with the officers
recommendation on this occasion right
anybody else on this I think I agree
with the propositions in made by counsel
Richards and second by counsel rock now
councillor Barnes you did say you could
be prepared to propose grants on this
I'm conscious the fact you didn't
actually propose that but we do have a
proposition to refuse and it's been
seconded okay right so it proposed that
we refuse in accordance with the
officers recommendation all those in
favor
please show five German those against
and abstentions to German thank you
therefore the committee resolves to
refuse application reference 19 / 0 0 4
7 5 / ful and we have no urgent business
tonight
concludes that meeting thank you very
much